what am I thinking I think averting the
blueprint this first of all I'm starting
to blueprint cuz it's self explanatory
it's the blueprint what up and I walk up
luck and I'm playing straw bench cut
I'll be giving the category I gotta have
one to start one to cut in one today
best handles I'm starting carry if you
ever seen like the Olympic game they
played and carried across the whole damn
team I need to like go see them
so basically Carillo starring Chris Paul
I'm blood got handled for gangs he like
the closest thing to Gary Payton but
just being hunted so I had to bench him
cuz I like Steph Curry
I like your handles but your shot is
killing your hands do all right
LeBron I'm starting be honest I'm [ __ ]
sorry James I got you know all three
kings
I think the synergy around LeBron is
safe
I think the dominance of the game is
Yanis James Harden's like Jesus for but
I need more than just a scorer see the
Onyx and LeBrons of scores as well but
they put it they get the team fully
involved that's why I kept me honest get
rich to die trying is uh definitely my
started the car to three I mention it
because they're just spiders Wayne can
not not listen to that and the blueprint
sorry I had to cut that hold up whoa
whoa whoa hell no right now back hold on
hold on hold on I'm starting the
blueprint what am I thinking
come on I'm starting the blueprint this
first of all I'm starting a blueprint
cuz it's self explainatory it's the
blueprint and I'm benching fifty because
I'm getting rich to die trying in Carter
three I'm sorry wait I had to cut this
all right you know how I was going back
my mind playing the bloop I'm like oh
hell I'm bugging the beat some crazy bug
enough basketball start baseball cut
football bench because first of all
baseball is way too [ __ ] hard
he'll wear bug and get hit with the ball
I smoke I'm [ __ ] ball football I bench
football because I like it but I don't
love it as much as basketball you know
so I'm just starving basketball fans to
meet basketball wasn't like like
everything I do in life like I compared
to basketball so Josh Smith um I started
I like Josh Swift but he was like the
left hand bandit like John Smith was
unstoppable like hey the primary it's
time I'll start Josh Smith I'll Benchley
Williams just for the fact that we win
starts turning ugly I felt like like he
had to like get the feel for the NBA and
get the love from his team and get the
excitement from the coach so I'll come a
little early that's why I say who
wouldn't come off the bench of you the
truth because he always wasn't fired six
man I'm sorry the way I gotta cut you
just just because you didn't continue
the way he was playing from Orlando like
I don't know where you spiraled down
that here career I'm glad you picked it
right back up with the Lakers but got a
bench your big guys bro sorry and I
really know do i how do you like what up
man don't walk a [ __ ] this is my
start [ __ ] cut got a TV show coming on
March 12th on WE tv what the Flocka my
wife album coming out conversations the
beginning of this summer I got flock
ability to coming out October 5th I got
La foes knew it was coming bricks bought
monopolies gonna make sure you have to
clean up squat throw life